I think we're the only mullet bearing
municipal yeah marsupials yeah brah
I mean we definitely those [ __ ] hair
bears you know we're up there yeah the
hair bears the [ __ ] Afghanistan's but
we got that [ __ ] I got I got the damn
floor to follicle fountain back Steve I
mean we're in riffraff ganna stand
brothers in the neon neon nightmarish
sports studio we're showcasing sports
dude you got the ghost of Tony Gwynn of
Tony Gwynn outside yeah I got Kirby
Pucket
oh you got Cecil fielding out he's a
feel they're still working the big one
oh yeah got the Big Unit I got Randy
Johnson hit our back yard mulch oh yeah
molten mullets he got he's doing he's
put any put in he's investing in some
type of planner II now he had good hair
he had a nice set backstage how do you
feel differently now that you had the
million dollar Monica's Dale Dan Tony
and he only comfortable cuz I had like a
full head of just hair for like I'd had
braids for almost like ten years just I
just you know I mean oh yeah man you
said and I can still grow it out if I
want to if I keep it's just like when
it's when it's not hitting your ears and
you know I mean like the hair getting
your mouth and start like having this
front trimmed up and then the back you
know I mean it's just a lot easier wash
is easier to dry mm-hmm it looks better
people see it's a no-no yeah it sounds
better yeah when it's in the wind it has
a certain sound to it it's whispering
around has a snap yeah you know I mean I
think that's where the rice krispy those
rice krispies treat those three I think
they had moments they made him cut him
when they were but that's how I got that
snap crackle pop oh dude I look man if
you if you look at old pictures of him
boys all three of them mm-hmm you know
and one of them had an arm was a celiac
had celiac disease was the red-haired
boy I think it was because one who
couldn't even eat the treats they made
oh wow and not really I know that hurt a
lot of it didn't hurt people's feelings
but you know anyway it was so him even
being able to be a part of it was really
a miracle yeah but yeah they uh they all
had mullets when they were younger
that's funny
you knew that yeah I've had a feeling
who would be the top let's do the top
five people that should have mullets
because it would change how they [ __ ]
on right now yeah okay Lloyd you go
first okay first up if I had to think of
a good person that could get a mullet
cuz it would help him I think operate a
little bit better and really show who he
is I go with Bill trill Clinton you
think he'd go back running for prayers
oh I did I think he if I can run through
a couple more legs up us if he [ __ ]
threw one on the food cuz bill man I've
been through Arkansas and he they said
you know a lot of ladies still know I'm
gonna remember him fondly and I think if
he had a mullet it would really take it
to the next level you go all white or
let her diet I don't know I don't know
if Hillary would let him died I think
yeah she'd probably kick him out that
day back on your old [ __ ] again ain't
you yeah get out of hole Arkansas you're
gonna make me look bad in front of my
peers you have any peace my state then
they get into it cuz he got that far
back in if I recall correctly you didn't
even even pick me yeah I think you you
picked another man you picked that guy
who did the UM the Pete Herman Cain you
was [ __ ] jock and Herman Cain back in
a day Pizza Pizza Pizza
you want it you wanna do you really want
a Billy Mays yeah yeah you'll pick him
for Foursquare ball yeah yeah you want
it uh um you want a Billy Ray Cyrus I
saw you looking at his [ __ ] overall
stress I saw I saw you over there was
looking at his Instagram stories yeah I
was over your shoulder yeah I saw you
reading [ __ ] corn bread recipes that
his mother I've written yeah yeah yeah
you cared more about him you don't even
[ __ ] care about me
your Guillory you put you know when you
a baby you had Teddy Ruxpin you put a
tape in the back and it was just his
voice oh just cradling you to sleep
audio cradles yeah you got audio cradles
from ah Billy Mays back there yeah you
had a Teddy Ruxpin trying to sell you a
[ __ ] OxiClean yeah no wonder you
can't get any rest at night you know I
think should should should film more
movies who I think Adam Sandler should
grow a mullet and
and really just get ripped and just
showcasing shoot happy gilmore - yeah I
can see that boy how happy is how I only
would it would be called
that's happier now yeah happier than
ever happier now and I would like to
even see him be in a wheelchair in
jacked as [ __ ]
because if you here's the thing I
noticed I got a couple buddies that was
one of guy got hit by lightning or fell
into a hole or something and another guy
his legs never he never had any good
legs from the beginning right and so
he's all jet when you just focus on the
upper body mm-hmm like on hand we got
height lights out but his dude is so
[ __ ] jacked man it's a different
level you know but I could see that Adam
Sandler if he had a nice mullet what
kind of good movies would he make
different ones he should he should to
retake over Rambo
because I know that shooting a Rambo but
what if they switched up went by Rambo
eight and it was it was two Rambo's it
was me me and Adam sands yeah well I see
that Horatio Sanz
or Horatio Sandler uh uh Norma Donald
should grow a mullet and just get ripped
oh yeah and he's like yeah yeah he does
a Colonel Sanders movie but it's a
documentary but it's all way off in the
Colonel Sanders is it is his twin
brother yeah yeah and him and Colonel
Sanders fight and then he beats Colonel
Sanders and opens up a place called norm
MacDonald's and it's a [ __ ] place
with Lucy's ah yeah so I take over
McDonald's yeah so no trademark
infringement issues and you go in there
you think you're gonna get something
eaten it's Norma Donnell in there with a
[ __ ] just with a hatch that are just
[ __ ] you up crank and chords dude how
much I can't believe nobody's funding
this [ __ ] we got I don't sound I could
do it you know I can't know about I
can't believe we can't anybody to fund
these ideas alright so you got it we got
Bill Clinton we got out of Sandler but
dude I heard they're making Tran bow
it's like a trans transgender bollocks
oh well that makes you the Bowflex it
makes you dick wet yeah Bowflex sent me
a free Bowflex here it's in the bad yard
Wow
I'm serious I thought I thought the you
know a friend of mine his sister hooked
up with Tony Little from Tony Little
gizelle freestyler further from the
commercials yep who's a long time ago my
friend Darren you don't know him he he
used to live my by me when I was younger
um do you know I got a [ __ ] from
Jared from Subway sister a long time ago
in the French Quarter damn okay so we
got Bill Clinton Adam Sandler I think
think of somebody good news I think
Ricki Lake should come back with her own
show and she's just she's molded out
she's like listen I'm gonna tell y'all
what's cool what's not cool y'all are
just not y'all ain't it yeah this is
what this is what's going on this is
cool and she just does a whole show on
this is cool this ain't yes and she just
airs everybody out puts it all out she's
like listen cuz she's mixed first of all
so she could talk [ __ ] by everybody and
then she got yeah then she had the side
slashes - he does she should that thicky
lake they used to call her because she
got dick for a while and she just she's
just in there with the mullet and she's
just sitting there and she's dancing and
everything but not regular like Ellen
dances like just moving and it's
easygoing now she's rich she's out there
getting it and she and she's telling
everybody now this is this is where it's
at yeah yeah y'all need to quit [ __ ]
driving this uh
this Toyota Camry ain't it listen these
super or hatchbacks [ __ ] hatchback
brah what you need is to get that for
fest even put some [ __ ] 38s on it
damn what the hell were them things
called Suzuki truce troopers yeah but
you got to get a real Asian marinated
snap things on a cake yeah that was like
the the windbreaker of course yeah
you're like damn this thing doubles as a
[ __ ] light coat yeah you wear that
damn that click they let them on them
snaps Flo
yeah dude oh if he got cold out man
zip it up turn the heat on leave it lead
the car run about 30 minutes later heat
up take the key go right around a block
open I leave the heat cranking dude it
was it was like a windbreaker someone
you find something in the pocket of the
doors it was like a pot it was like it's
so stretchy
yeah you finally your credit card in
error or a stick of gum man just a silly
straw yeah - another ste one that's
somebody been chewing on with a little
karma the frog on the top the green one
ma'am
yeah Ricki Lake would be really good if
she grew her hair out she needs to do
that good more people were respect her -
I think she needs to make a comeback
they're coming back I'll do more to
combat seonyu our barstool sports they
anytime somebody gets a mullet they post
it mm-hmm any time and do you feel like
people I notice a lot of people come to
me with it but in you know in other
countries and I know you know in other
countries this is just a hockey haircut
or it's a in some countries in Amsterdam
this is a woman's haircut
this is predominantly a young woman and
a lot of times if it's a young white
girl that dates a lot of brothers don't
have this hair you know jewelry is
jewelry but diamonds of diamonds yeah
you know I mean a lot of people can
mistake something for one thing just
because old cars the cars with
Lamborghini Lamborghini yeah
and I'll talk about that for is light
but when you have the mullet and you're
doing it the million dollar mullet
mm-hmm
that's a whole other you know that's a
whole other station for that that's a
whole of the station verification and it
looks strong it looks like the back is
on creating yeah I mean I mean III hate
I'll take this out I'll throw back on my
dad yeah I'd love to see a little more
you know this isn't this isn't know that
people ask if I have a zipper on it yeah
that ain't no sipping tea huh hahaha
dude that's like that [ __ ] Jim
McMahon huh remember him who was the guy
that played uh Brian Bosworth Brian
Bosworth man you know yeah the Xavier
McDaniel with the pant with the back
Panhandle yeah
that's that yeah that's that really
that's that [ __ ] uh that's that
Rapunzel man time I soaked this sweat
bando is that bro Ponzo